we begin with breaking news from
afghanistan where the northern city of
kunduz has fallen into taliban hands
after afghan forces failed to hold the
strategically important city
afghanistan's sixth largest city near
the border with tajikistan kunduz has
been the scene of fierce fighting the
taliban is reported to also be advancing
into the center of sharipul another
northern provincial capital
and for more i'm joined by journalist
ali latifi in kabul ali
what what do we know about the situation
in the north of afghanistan right now so
the north of afghanistan we're seeing
several points with intense fighting and
back and forth claims by the taliban
that they have taken over different
areas and really at this point the only
way we can confirm these things is by
speaking to people on the ground and
having them tell us that yes the taliban
are
within these government offices and that
they've raised their flags and that
they've
essentially you know made it into the
central parts of these cities
because the government
sorry is not giving any direct
confirmation uh about
uh what's been going on they have yet to
outright confirm that condos
in the south or santa pola or any of
these other places
have come under taliban control but what
we do see is that they will release
statements and videos saying that there
are clearance operations and other
operations for instance they just
released the ministry of defense a video
of a commando in kunduz saying that
they've been conducting
intense operations over the last 24
hours and that they've kept
the taliban fighters from allegedly
making it to central points in the city
which is something that locals are
refuting saying no they've actually made
it into places like the prison into
police headquarters and things like that
so it's a lot of back and forth at this
point
right so no outright confirmation yet
from the afghan government but yet how
significant are these gains for the
taliban
um
condos is definitely a very significant
gain if you look at sort of their
strategy over the last few weeks or the
last couple months they really try to
take one of the major cities of the
country so they tried hard for kandao
they tried hard for lashkar ganeman and
they tried hard for hirat they weren't
able to take any of those and the first
cities that they were able to take zara
and shibaran they're considered smaller
they're not necessarily provinces that
get a lot of attention even from the
government they've always sort of been
ignored but a province like condos you
know given its population give it get
strategic location and also the fact
that they had been able to take it uh
two times prior in 2015 and 2016
is you know to the taliban it's a good
propaganda point you know it it's
something that they can sell very easily
so kudos is the third provincial capital
to fall in the past three days are the
taliban advancing quicker than expected
after the withdrawal of foreign troops
it seems that way but but the one thing
we have to remember is that a lot of
these advances are eventually repelled
um so
you know if we see that in the next few
days shibaran zarage and kunduz come
back into taliban hands that will come
back to the question that we've had all
this time of how long can the taliban
hold control over an area yes they can
take it you know for instance when the
game was mainly about districts over you
know the last few weeks the districts
would be taken and then a few days or a
couple weeks later the government would
say we've retaken that district so now
the question will be
if districts were trading hands so so
quickly in the past how long can they
keep cities or can they actually
maintain control over these cities for
extended periods of time
ali thank you very much ali letifi
journalist in kabul thank you very much
you